hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this it's Tamara's never seen and
today I'm watching Suicide Squad before
anyone jumps down my throat yes I was in
the Suicide Squad clipless review
I played katana I loved katana
no no nothing about katana but damn did
I nail that cosplay okay I was actually
pretty hyped for Suicide Squad when the
trailers were coming out the premise is
so good and then it came out and
everyone was so upset with it an anti
Suicide Squad and just like disappointed
bring back this Harley I know this
Harley from the animated series growing
up is my loved Harley Harley is an
excellent character I know that this
newer Harley is from a comic version and
I have not read that so chain gruff
sound like an 80 year old men who's mad
about the internet changing actually
that could be anyone
12 year olds are also mad about that
we'll see if this new Harley Quinn can
change my mind
[Music]
okay she changed my mind
I have some unpopular opinions about
this movie as I can't wait to share them
with you I liked it way more than I
thought I was going to like it maybe
it's because I went in with a very very
low bar set but my god I found myself
really enjoying it it's a super dope
premise super dope characters dope did
you dope dope dope dope you know I think
they did a good job for having a film
where we literally didn't know any of
the people that we were watching they
talk so much about how Marvel is built
up this back catalogue of 10 years of
Marvel single story movies that's why
they're able to do Avengers infinity war
but then they talk a lot about how DC
doesn't do that and it's so true but
instead of trying to do like one or two
like small little like single films and
then just dive right in they're like nah
we're just going to go for it and like
really went in hard and we didn't know
any of them so they had the kind of like
list format where they introduced
everybody individually one of the time
and you kind of got to see like their
best clips and their best abilities I
really enjoyed that there's like a lot
of cool information at once you also got
to see a lot of the other DC characters
or just have them mentioned which is
pretty cool you actually saw Batman
multiple times it was good it's
referenced that Harley Quinn kills Robin
just rude where else can I wear this
costume
Superman is references being killed not
gonna put this on
too much superhero lingerie but not my
principle once woman what the hell
Suicide Squad what the hell she's the
best you got DC she's the best the story
could have been better
yes final act could have been better yes
the fighting was all dark and cloudy and
honestly I really only cared about dead
shots and Harley Quinn but that being
said I really cared about Deadshot Quinn
oh oh also I cared about katana she's
super badass
I love Biola Davis and that was really
fun seeing them all together I know a
lot of people don't like Amanda Palmer
Palmer Palmer as character I really
really loved Amanda that she was a
badass idiot who I loved
I didn't however love what's his name
slingshot boomerang like hopscotch guy I
forget his name I didn't like him or
killer croc or El Diablo I also didn't
see why Suicide Squad won the Oscar for
hair and makeup
I mean basically if you don't know the
story is about this character Amanda
Palmer Palmer Palmer who works in the
government trying to assemble a team to
save the world because Superman is dead
therefore he can't he's totally dead you
guys he's absolutely dead no doubt about
it my mind dad she figures she can use
supervillains
instead of superheroes and create the
Suicide Squad what a killer concept I
bet the comics are rad like I said when
I was watching the trailers I was super
pumped for it and I heard like terrible
thing and it's not a masterpiece by any
means one thing I will talk about is how
I really did not enjoy the Joker what an
impassible role to play after Heath
Ledger did it so perfectly I wouldn't
want to do that at all I really would
not want to take that over that being
said I don't think it was good I know
that I just said like the different
Hartley's what it was fine and it works
and this has got to be like a different
interpretation of the Joker
I'm Shannen he also didn't want to just
like play by play try to do what he
pleasure did but it didn't work for me
he was creepy in a bad way in like not
alike oh he's creepy in like a way
that's like oh yeah I know I said I
didn't like El Diablo but at one point
he goes like this and makes fire in his
hands and it just says bye and fire
that's a major movie this is like
halfway through the film I just wrote oh
it's Slipknot I mean it's a band babe
that's when katana comes and I like had
completely forgot about katana and I
played her I played her God she's a
badass this is more my style oh wow they
killed slip none what a surprise I want
so much more for Will Smith so so so
much more I feel like he was so
underutilized in this I can't because I
only really cared about him in Harley so
I just want a him in Harley movie
everyone's like aw man make a Harley and
Joker movie about me
no wait is the Enchantress that girl
from balerion I haven't seen valerian
but is that the girl from full layer in
also the villains and this are really
bad I know everyone's technically a
villain but like The Enchantress and her
brother
they are goofy as hell and the
voiceovers for them the voice dubs are
he'll be really bad poorly done
there's also crazy sectionalized
fighting I don't know if there's like an
actual term for that but it's like when
Deadshot is fighting the brother villain
and then like no one else is fighting at
that time it's kind of like everyone
just stops to lick just like look and
listen like check it out and then when
that doesn't happen then the Enchantress
is fighting a power it's like very
sexualized and they doesn't feel like
everyone's fighting at the team
everyone's just kind of sitting back
watching one person fight el Diablo
almost had the brother villain but
everyone was just sitting there why
didn't everyone just pile on while El
Diablo was kicking butt like it just
doesn't make sense
this really stupid dumb writing also the
final fight is really dark and cloudy
and muddy and you can't tell what's
really going on and it's the final fight
sweet perfect just what everyone wants
then they destroy the Enchantress and
her brother with friendship pretty much
then you get a set up for the second
most incredibly ambitious of you guys to
create this set up for the second one
though if I'm being honest I would watch
a second if it was like better no I
would still watch it watch it I really
really really really want to like this
more than I do and honestly I don't hate
it I kind of do like it I just there's a
there's a there's a lot to be worked
upon why is look not even here
yes Margot Robbie is good but Harley
Quinn is a personified Hot Topic t-shirt
yes that's why honestly I was kind of
put off by the film she was so popular
every convention I go to there's like 50
Harley Quinn's you're questioning girls
and guys and everybody everyone you're
crushing it but I was just overwhelmed
by the amount of her
Quinn's and also was missing the old
Harley Margot Robbie's great same with
Will Smith that's why their characters
came through and everyone else's didn't
sorry you won't care about Deadshot cuz
he's just Will Smith playing Will Smith
again yeah but I love when Will Smith
plays Will Smith so I kind of gonna give
it a path
I just love Will Smith where's he been
stop it in anything good recently I
didn't even see this that good
you'd be confused why they needed all
the flashbacks well it did seem
excessive but also it's a movie about a
bunch of characters that haven't been
introduced yet so I feel like I
understand where they were coming from
with all of those it's just it wasn't it
was an exceptional amount all style no
substance I think that's a good way to
put it
it was so cool in its style and that's
why it left me wanting more I wanted
more of that but just with some
substance a little bit came through a
tiny bit of substance came through a
little bit with margot robbie and a tiny
bit with Deadshot and i like to step up
and his his daughter and I liked Margot
Robbie's story about how she started off
as the doctor who I really want to
cosplay as by the way yeah it's mostly
style very little substance is what I'll
say I had a blast of a lot of makeup on
my face this is the fourth video that I
filmed today so it looked kind of like
The Enchantress a little bit a little
bit of the enchantress up in here so I'm
not going to do the dance but I will get
eat the face nailed it great thank you
so much I will see you all next week
but why so serious I got a dress up more
this is fun
[Music]
[Applause]
you